today on the matt walsh show christy
gnome the governor of south dakota has
become the latest conservative to
surrender
seemingly surrender on the women's
sports issue today we'll talk about
why that's a bad idea this is a this is
a hill worth dying on and we'll talk
about why also
five headlines including one woke
company releases an
ad that promotes transgenderism in
children and another world company pulls
their ads from
the daily wire because one leftist with
a twitter account and five followers
told it to
and our daily cancellation will deal
with the latest celebrity to come out in
support of
fat acceptance that and much more today
on the matt wall show
[Music]
[Applause]
you know as a conservative i'm often
told that whatever opinion i happen to
be expressing at any given moment
is quote not the hill to die on no
matter what the opinion is no matter the
issue being discussed i
i am sure to hear from a hundred members
of the peanut gallery
who will all warn in ominous tones that
uh
by by expressing this point of view
whatever it is i am not only dying on a
hill
but to make matters worse it's the wrong
hill
you sure you want to die on this hill
they ask the question is rhetorical
they've already decided that i should
not want to die on it but i will if i
keep talking
now the thing about these people and
their dire warnings about untimely
deaths on wrong hills
is that they never give any suggestions
as to the right hill
now they're sure that this issue
whatever the issue happens to be
is not worth this kind of fight but they
won't indicate
which issue is worth this kind of fight
it's become apparent to me that
the don't die on this hill crowd
especially those who call themselves
conservatives
are so confident that every hill is the
wrong hill precisely because
they've decided that no hill is the
right hill
they're prepared to surrender every hill
except defeat on every issue
one at a time one after another until
there are no more hills left to defend
then they can turn around and triumphant
defeat
shrug their shoulders and say well looks
like all the hills have been taken
and then go home to their couch in their
netflix account and live the rest of
their lives in
the comfort of subjugation now my
strategy
is quite the opposite of this i would
rather die on every hill
no matter how great or small doesn't
require any real bravery to take this
position you know as dying on a hill
means
not really dying but really just
enduring mean comments from people on
the internet
uh i've died on a million hills and yet
yet i live
because death on a metaphorical hill is
nothing like death on a physical one it
turns out
but while the ever-growing contingent of
cowards and defeat fetishes
on the right continue to surrender hill
after hill in succession
abandoning their posts faster than the
minneapolis pd abandoned their precinct
to blm arsonist
it's important to identify i think the
most important hills for the rest of us
to defend
as much as i as i said i would love to
die on all of them and i do choose all
of them
from from the sm from emojis all the way
up okay in terms of
in terms of the severity of the issue
but even so i think it's important to to
figure out what are the most
important issues the most important
hills and i would say that one of them a
central hill perhaps the central hill
is certainly the issue of gender now to
acquiesce to the left's agenda on this
front to submit to their attempted
erasure of biological reality is to give
up on
logic truth morality and science
in a word it is to give up on everything
everything that matters it is to abandon
the last hill governor christie gnome of
south dakota
to the surprise of many not to the
surprise of me because
i'm never surprised to see this from a
republican i don't care who it is
but she is one republican willing and
ready to do just that to abandon the
last hill
after excitedly encouraging her state
legislature to pass a bill
banning uh males from female sports she
suddenly at the last minute changed her
mind
upon receiving the bill on her desk the
bill that she said she would sign
a bill which would put you know um put a
halt to the
to the march of gender madness at least
in south dakota and at least in the
realm of sports
after receiving it gnome flinched she
announced that actually she couldn't
sign it as is
mostly because she doesn't want the band
to extend to the collegiate level
her reason is that banning males from
women's sports in college
might make the ncaa mad and they might
try to
quote punish south dakota for it now i'm
not
exaggerating i'm not being reductive
here that's really her reason that's
what she said
she doesn't want to make them mad
because they might punish her
here she is explaining it at a press
conference yesterday listen
i want to be very palms up with each and
every one of you
here today these legal scholars think
that south dakota's chances of winning a
lawsuit against the ncaa
are very low the ncaa is a private
association
that means they can do what they want to
do and even though fundamentally
i fundamentally disagree with them when
it comes to this issue if south dakota
passes a law that's against their policy
they will likely take punitive action
against us that means they could pull
their tournaments from the state of
south dakota
they could pull their home games they
could even prevent our athletes from
playing in their league
that's their prerogative so a fight that
doesn't truly protect women's sports
and doesn't allow women to compete
ultimately is going to hurt south dakota
families
and if the ncaa did take action against
the state of south dakota we could sue
them
i know we could do that but these
respected legal scholars informed me
that that we would likely lose at that
level facing the court circumstances
that we have in front of us
so we could pass a law then we could get
punished
then we could face expensive litigation
at taxpayer expense
and then we could lose well there it is
now gnome was on with tucker later that
night to
further explain her position and it was
more of what you just heard there
she's concerned that imposing sanity and
fairness at the college level
may spark a fight with the ncaa that she
doesn't think that they can win she
thinks she's going to lose
now this is i think we could say the
most quintessentially
republican line of reasoning that you'll
ever hear
to surrender a fight preemptively based
on the fear that you might lose it
well we're going to lose this fight so
let's just lose it on purpose
i'm gonna lose it anyway and she's also
worried that amazon
might be mad and might abandon the state
as well we should know now
to me you know these seem like
profoundly unthreatening threats
this is one of those things where is
that a promise or a threat kind of
situation
the ncaa might flee from your state
amazon might go with them good
let them go who cares
but why why is that a problem that seems
to me to be more of a perk
if anything but whether it should make
us
sad or not if the ncaa and amazon
doesn't want to be our friend the fact
is that the consequences are worth
suffering let's pretend that those are
really are
dire or terrible consequences so what
i mean quite literally any consequence
would be worth suffering for this
and i really mean that any consequence
and a lawsuit certainly a lawsuit that
you're going to lose
that's a consequence worth suffering
because this is not just about women's
sports
let's be clear about this this is not
merely a matter of devising
some practical plan to make sure that
the girls of south dakota
can play volleyball unencumbered it's
not
just what this is about as the left has
pointed out there haven't been many
biological males attempting to intrude
into female sports in that state it's
been a problem
in other states and it's going to
increasingly be a problem
but in south dakota it has so far not
been a significant problem
and it may never be a significant
problem in south dakota
the problem may never reach epidemic
levels there that's true
but that's not the point at least that's
not the whole point
the point is to make a statement to draw
a line
to defend what is sane and reasonable
because
it is sane and reasonable it shouldn't
be necessary but it is
laws are not just laws they are
messages society communicates its values
communicates what it finds acceptable
through laws now the left knows this and
they
act upon it they use the law they use it
to help shape public opinion
to help shape what society sees as
acceptable
what it sees as wrong and right and it
works
now the right one of its many problems
still doesn't understand this
it used to understand this but it
doesn't anymore
many on the right still want to pretend
that the fight over women's sports is
motivated
purely and only by our concern over our
daughters having a fair opportunity
to be captain of the track team it's not
j
yes that's part of the concern
but that's not the whole thing if it was
just about your daughter on the track
team
then i would say you know it's actually
not that big of a deal
but that's not it
you know we all know that's not the
biggest issue here
the biggest issue is that the left is
attacking reality itself
on the most fundamental level that's
the issue and women's sports is just
one arena for that fight
but it's an important arena and it's an
arena
that everybody is looking at now and
focused on that's what makes it
important
the consequences of surrendering it
of losing in this arena would have
ramifications that go
far beyond your daughter's track team
the consequences ultimately are again
that we give up on reality
that we live in a society that simply
fundamentally
does not recognize reality and truth
anymore at all
that seems like a big consequence to me
that seems like a fight worth having
i don't know what fight is worth having
if that's not
i don't know how we can have any fights
if we don't all live in reality if we're
not defending reality and truth
and that's why we choose this hill to
die on any republicans who
would turn tail and run from it are of
no use to us
totally useless if you can't get it
right
on this issue you're useless
and that certainly goes for christinom
too
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
we're excited about a new sponsor on the
the show today ex-chair now look you
you maybe like me you spend a lot a lot
of your day sitting down
you know depending what you do for a
living i know for me i spend a whole lot
of time sitting down
more time than i should certainly be
spending sitting down and what that
means is that just like your mattress
matters because of how much time you
spend
laying down on your mattress and
sleeping uh the kind of chair you have
it really does matter it matters for
your comfort it matters for your health
it matters in so many ways
and that's why i'm so excited to have x
chair which i am
currently sitting in as we speak and
enjoy every minute of it
xchair has you covered for your office
needs the secret is not only their
patented dynamic
variable lumber support which offers
unbelievable
lumbar support to your lower back but
now thanks to their new
xhmt technology you can also get heat
and massage therapy
while you're sitting at your desk i that
we have a massage function on this chair
i don't use it during the show because
that seems inappropriate but
it is it is wonderful i can tell you the
xhmt delivers heat and massage
technology right to your core helping
increase blood flow muscle recovery and
energy all perks that make working from
home or office
a joy it even has four different massage
modes and fast warming
heat technology for therapy uh when
you're sore
and on top of all that it's it is an
extremely comfortable chair you sit down
in it and you say
i don't i don't want to ever give up get
up again i can't recommend it enough
this is why i love my ex chair you'll
love it too x chair
is on sale now for 100 off 100 off right
now go to xchairwalsh.com
and that's the letter x chairwalsh.com
or call one
eight four four four x chair extra is a
30 day guarantee of complete comfort and
you can finance your purchase for as
little
as 30 bucks a month go to
xchairwalsh.com now
use code x wheels for free x-wheel blade
bladecasters
that's again xchairwalsh.com
okay so uh this from the daily wire
says the hygiene company harry's dropped
advertising
on the daily wire last week apparently
in response to an anonymous twitter
account
with nearly no followers the twitter
account that had garnered
five followers by monday afternoon
posted on march 7th
a message to harry's objecting to its
advertising on the daily wires
the michael knowles show which uh you
may have heard of that show before
for its allegedly homophobic and
transphobic content
now this again just some rant i don't
even think it's one of those accounts
they didn't have a they don't even have
an avatar there's no profile photo it's
just like a
it's just a random anonymous account
from one person with five followers this
is this is somebody with
zero power and influence like does not
matter what they think
the easiest kind of person to ignore
and um but harry's which is a you know
multi-million
dollar company responds and and they say
thanks for bringing this up
we condemn the views in this video
referring to a video of nulls talking
about um
the transgender issue and it says we can
we condemn the views in this video which
are inexcusable and at odds with our
longtime support of the lgbtq plus
community
we've ended our relationship with this
show and are looking into our
sponsorships
to prevent any values uh misalignment
going forward
so you know this
you see what it takes this is the kind
this is the kind of power on the left
this is the kind of
institutional power that um that those
on the left have for all the talk about
how ins you know if you're if you're a
white male you have
allegedly all this privilege and all
this power i i still have not
seen it i don't know where to cash in
i've been asking for years
i mean i'm not above cashing in if i can
cash in on my white male privilege and
get all kinds of perks
i'll do it just tell me where but i
haven't found it yet
now being on the left though does he
see privilege is afforded according to
ideology not according to
to uh not not not according purely to
race
what matters first and foremost number
one is your ideology
because if you don't have the right
ideology there is zero privilege for you
in the culture today
so you gotta start with that now and
then once you have the right the quote
right ideology
then from there you get even more
privilege depending on uh what victim
groups you belong to and so forth
but but think about this privilege you
you have so much privilege
that from an anonymous account with five
followers
you can demand that a multi-million
dollar company change its marketing
strategy
and they'll do it they'll just right
away say well
okay if you say so
so on the right we can't even like we
can't even us
even us um dastardly white males we
can't even conceive of that kind of
cultural power
because it would never happen ever
it would never if you have a twitter
account with a few followers and you
sent a a message to any company and say
hey yeah i really don't like that
advertisement but
it offended me it's going to ignore you
and and the thing here is that that
harry's it's not
it's not only that they dropped the
advertising which
they're obviously free to do um it's not
just that
but as the god king jeremy boring
pointed out on twitter it it
it's that they on their way out the door
they also condemned you know the show
that they were just advertising with
and by extension condemn the whole
audience
the people that they were that they were
just trying to sell their product to on
the way out they condemned all of them
that's a bunch of transphobes and bigots
so this is this is more than that this
is more than
a company making a decision about of
course they have the right no one's
saying they don't have the right to do
that
but on the way out the door like the
kick in the butt and the way out the
door
you were just working with this show did
you not know that it was a conservative
show
really did you did you really not know
that of course you did
but on the way out condem the show the
audience everyone
that's the way it goes now here to kind
of make my point we'll move on to number
two here
uh so that's that's the the woke company
harry's
um which by the way look harry's they
can make decisions
about who they advertise with they're
free to do that in a free market
and you and i can make decisions on
what companies we choose to support and
those
and we on the right need to start being
a lot more
um we have to start making more more
considered decisions
as far as that goes
and as far as i you know i'm not a big
fan of boycotts in principle
but if a company is saying
we don't want your business we hate you
we think you're a bunch of bigots we
don't want your business
then as a matter of basic self-respect
we don't have to call it a
boycott call whatever you want as a
matter of basic self-respect
i think we have to say well okay then
i'm not going to give you my money
we should not be forcing our money
into the hands of people who don't want
it and are saying i don't want your
money
you're you're horrible people well i
don't care take it anyway please take my
money from me
that's what harry's is saying if you're
going by harry's remember remember and
you're a conservative remember they hate
you
and you're forcing your money on them
they don't want it
you got to think about whether you
really want to do that
now i now it's easy for me to say i
obviously am not that
i kind of think razors are overrated as
it goes already but
so maybe it's easy for me to say okay so
that's harry that's one woke company
and then number two here we got another
woke company uh pantene
the makers of um pretty much all the
toiletry
all the companies are going woke but
especially in the toiletry realm
uh that's where it's uber woke there so
pantene maker of i believe shampoo
has um become the latest corporation to
jump on the trans
indoctrination bandwagon and i'm going
to play this ad for you
which is a really repulsive and
grotesque ad on many many levels
and i guarantee you if you're a
conservative with you with an anonymous
account and five followers
you can express your outrage over this
ad to pantene and they're not gonna give
a damn
okay they're not gonna do anything in
response to that because they don't care
about you but here's the uh let's play
this this is the ad for pantheon this is
um
uh a we're being told about
a young boy who decided to be to become
a girl
and is in the middle of this gender
transition and is being helped along in
that transition by his two mothers
so two mothers his two lesbian mothers
end up with a boy who wants to be a girl
what a coincidence i mean that's it it's
got to be you know it's
how can we possibly draw any connection
there at all we we simply can't
let's watch the ad now here it is
so as for lgbtq kids hair is more than
you think
it's how you are seen sawyer is
an old soul she is our
spunky and creative kiddo
sawyer also happens to be a transgender
girl
i remember the first time she was out in
the community
wearing the clothing she wanted in her
hair and she kind of
was herself and that was the first day
where i was not
he's the opposite of himself she has
always been
super gender creative that doesn't mean
anything that doesn't mean anything
gender creative is not
that doesn't mean anything once she told
us that she
identified as a girl she immediately
wanted to grow her hair out
that must mean he's a girl if you wanted
to grow his hair out what other
explanation could you possibly have my
insides
match my outsides this is a kid
who knew who she was from such a young
age
no he didn't because no kid does because
they're kids about your kids
being loved and accepted so
i'm always telling sawyer to never hide
who she is
always be her oh no no you're you're
telling him exactly that to hide who he
is that's exactly what you're helping
him do
you lunatic you abusive
lunatic everybody loves everybody no
matter what path you follow
it means i can be who i
am no matter what it doesn't matter
because everybody loves me my advice is
just be yourself and don't let anybody
tell you who you are
[Music]
yeah that poor kid
that poor kid i feel so bad for these
kids what hope do they have
having parents like this having these
lunatic abusive parents
that kid should be removed from the home
and those those parents should be in
prison this is
among the worst forms of abuse that you
could possibly inflict on a child
this is psychological and sexual abuse
uh on on
on such a deep level that you
you are warping everything about them
there's their
sense of themselves you are warping
some of the worst abuse you'll ever see
and it's being
and we're being told about it the
abusive parents are sitting there
the nice inspirational music in the
background
and they're using it to sell shampoo
that's how accepted and normalized they
want this to be let me tell you
something
if you still go out and buy pantene
products whoever you
anyone listen if you go out and buy
pantene products you're pathetic
if you would still go and buy their
products after watching that this is a
this is a company
that is using child abuse to sell their
product
anyone who would watch that and still
buy the product is a
pitiful excuse for a person
if that's not going to convince you
there should not be one if you are
call yourself conservative i don't care
what you call yourself if you are a sane
normal person
you should never go near another pantene
product for the rest of your life
based on that it is
no different if if this was a if this
was an ad
encouraging physical abuse of a child we
were being told
how that child is is you know locked in
a closet
and and beaten with sticks and stuff
like that and and
and they were they were telling us that
with the inspirational music
and saying how wonderful it is for the
child
would anyone buy that product ever again
we would be so horrified
would say this is the worst company on
earth
this is no different this is just as bad
if not worse
that is a child who's being ruined by
those parents
ruined
you listen what he said he said um
you know when he wears girl's clothes
girl clothes his insides match his
outsides now
that that is a perfectly
expected and even reasonable thing to
hear
from a child who's been indoctrinated
into this
by his parents but as adults
we know that that doesn't make any sense
what do you mean what do you mean you
have girl insides that doesn't
mean anything it makes
zero sense as adults we know that
you can't expect a child to know it
unless you tell them
because children don't know anything
unless you tell them
a young boy as i've said a million times
a young boy
does not know who he is you have to help
him figure that
out and when he says i'm a girl
he doesn't know what that statement
means
he doesn't understand what he's saying
and if you don't believe me whenever you
hear a boy say that
all you have to ask him all you have to
ask him is
what do you mean hey sawyer when you say
you're a girl what do you mean by that
what do you mean
that's i ask my kids that kind of
question all the time when they say
things
because they often make statements that
don't make any sense because their kids
don't make any sense to me anyway so i
often have to say
what do you mean and then as they start
to describe it i i was
okay so this is what you mean see
because they're gonna they're gonna use
words that don't line up with what they
actually are trying to express
because they don't have the words yet
because their vocabulary is limited
and they also don't understand their own
emotions yet
because they're psychologically limited
and neurologically limited and their
brains aren't fully developed yet
and so as a parent my job so often is to
figure out what they actually think and
believe and want
and feel and to help them to realize
that about themselves
and to help them to express it
when you sit a kid down for at a
restaurant
to pick a meal they don't even know what
what they want to eat
they'll point to something on the menu
and you'll have to say as the parent no
no you don't really want that
i know you don't want it because i've
gotten you that meal six other times and
you didn't eat it
i know you think you want it but you
don't actually want it i'm gonna order
you the meal that you're actually gonna
eat
we as parents do that all the time
because kids don't know what they want
this is this is not some academic
discussion this is basic
child raising stuff this is this basic
stuff about about child psychology
and to deny it to that extent is is
horrific abuse
please don't ever buy pantene ever again
all right um so we went on that for a
little bit let's
uh let's move on to this okay i wanted
to play here's another video i wanted to
play um
a teacher did a remote field trip with
his class
he uh went to the zoo i'm not sure where
this was
where this took place but he he they're
still wherever he is they're still doing
zoom classes
and so this video went viral people
talking about what a wonderful
guy this guy is and what a wonderful
teacher is and he is a great teacher i
had no criticism of him
so he took his uh he had his laptop and
he's on his zoom class and he went to
the zoo uh to kind of take the kids on a
remote
field trip and let's watch that here
here it is why not still
go to the zoo and you guys can come with
so let's keep going
you got it what is this let's be great
readers
okay so he's taking the kids around with
the laptop and just showing them all the
different
what do we have now class all the
animals
a rhino a rhino
that's right and then the rana runs away
okay this is in washington state oh you
know i sorry there's my point with this
i watch this video and i think what that
that's a great teacher
as critical as i can be of teachers i i
don't deny that there's that there are
some great ones out there
so it's good he's doing that for the
kids but i i can't you know i watch that
like i can't watch it and see it as some
sort of
inspiring video i it's it's not
cute to me really it's deeply sad
is what it is there's no reason
this teacher is doing everything he can
but there's no reason why these kids
can't go to the zoo themselves and
there's no reason why they can't be in
the classroom
the zoo is open that's how he's there
the zoo is open there are people walking
around
so you can wherever this is happening
you can have
the zoo can be open people can go to the
zoo but they can't sit in a classroom
what's more important having the zoo
open or
classroom
that that's the first thing i think when
i see that i mean these poor kids
have been locked in their homes and now
they're reduced to
going on a zoo field trip through zoom
and you hear the i don't know how it
came through in the audio but you could
hear the comments from these kids like
oh this is the greatest
field trip ever and everything and
which again is great that they were
given that but it's also said
that they're so desperate for
interaction to be out in public that um
that they're excited to you know look at
animals on on zoom
i find that to be pretty sad all right
um
so what one other point one other thing
to mention here this is uh
from espn it says a 14th lawsuit
alleging sexual assault and
inappropriate conduct
was filed against deshaun watson by a
woman who says that she believes the
houston's court the houston texas
quarter but quarterback is a serial
predator
the lawsuit which was filed monday night
and appeared on the harris county
district clerk's
website tuesday morning alleges that
watson watson assaulted and harassed
the plaintiff by exposing himself to her
and touching her with his penis
the incident allegedly took place in
california just the second of the 14
allegations to take place outside the
houston area
the traveling massage therapist alleges
that when she arrived at the address
watson gave her
he led her to a room locked the doors
behind him after watson allegedly forced
plaintiff's hands onto his
uh onto his genitals during the massage
he allegedly told her i will not have
you sign an nda but don't ever talk
about this
now this is as it says there this is the
14th
uh lawsuit filed against desean watson
superstar quarterback
14th there's a 14 accusers and these are
people accused accusing him
not merely of harassment these are
assault accusations
and now the lawyer is wants her to be a
grand jury and
and is hoping for criminal charges as
well but 14 accusers
and some of these accusers have brought
receipts
now there was one that uh released text
messages allegedly from deshaun watson
and one of the text messages said
something like
it was after the fact and it said uh you
know sorry if you were uncomfortable
last time you know it looted now that
doesn't prove
that he committed sexual assault but if
the text messages are from from him
which would be easy to confirm
if it's true but assuming the text
message for him it it does
show that he was around this woman
something happened
and she was quote uncomfortable that's
not it's not proof
but it is it's it's more evidence than
you normally have in these situations
and then you add on top of that
14 13 other accusers
that's significant and you know i'm the
last one to
immediately believe any accusation
that's thrown around of course you have
to go through
innocent until proven guilty and all
that but um
at least that's how it goes in the court
of law and it should go
but as far as us as as as people making
reasonable
guesses as to what might have happened
hard for me to believe that 14 women
telling
very similar sounding stories some of
whom have text messages that they can
show
hard to believe that they're all lying
and yet the interesting thing is that
you don't you're not hearing a lot about
this story
this is a if you don't follow the nfl
i'd have to emphasize
a superstar quarterback
with 14 allegations of sexual assault
and it's uh yeah it's getting it of
course it's going to get some attention
it's getting some attention but
it's not if you go to espn.com right now
for example it's not the number one
story
so it's not being treated as headline
news in mass media or even in sports
media
it's being treated as sort of an
interesting side issue
and you have to really wonder you have
to wonder if this was a white
quarterback
if this was say tom brady with all these
accusations
would espn be treating it with the same
um
you know lack of interest and i would
say probably not
okay let's move now to reading the
comments this is from mary irwin says i
missed the videos from matt's car one of
the best parts was how annoyed people
got that he wasn't
in studio or something also i just
imagine people passing through the
kroger parking lot
seeing him spouting angry truth to his
dashboard
ha ha yeah that's that is
actually exactly what would happen with
those car videos
i was some crazy lunatic in a car
shouting just shouting at the dashboard
and yeah people would people would often
pass by
and stare in like what is this guy doing
the other thing about doing the car
videos you know is that it would i don't
know if
this uh came across it probably did if i
was dripping with sweat when i did those
videos
um because it got really hot in the
summer that was one practice one
logistical problem
i couldn't really have the windows on
rolled down uh because of
the noise so i would roll the windows up
and it would be like 600 degrees in
there
i was risking my life i hope you know
that
um cerebral method
says it's a good point about biden the
men who crave power are best fitted to
acquire it
and least fitted to exercise it which is
why having an unbiased media is so
important
yeah you always and that is that's the
irony that's the problem
that um you're not going to become
president
these days are really any day unless you
desperately want to be president
and biden has desperately wanted to be
president for decades
so you're probably not going to become
president unless you desperately want it
but if you desperately want it then
you're kind of like the last person who
should be president
and we're seeing that now with biden um
steve
boyher says they added what bike lanes
in my town they actually added them to
the right sides of an already existing
four-lane road
through town causing the road to become
narrower now the cars are riding in
narrower lanes and the ruts created
prior to the bike lane cause our cars to
attempt to stay in the lane
while fighting the ruts yeah we make
everything
everyone is less safe but at least we've
accommodated the the the cyclists and
their recreational activity so
you know if you get into a car accident
if you get into a head-on collision
because you're you're you're
the lanes are too close together now at
least take solace in the fact that
this happened so that a cyclist could
have some some recreation
get a little cardio in um
and emily says i was grocery shopping
with my mask below my nose and some lady
comes up to me and says that the masks
don't work if i don't wear it properly i
ignored her and then she followed me to
the checkout and harassed me again
i then responded to her where's your
second mask clearly she was not an
authority on the efficacy of masks as
she was only wearing one such a
hypocrite great response
yeah this is my my policies number one
you know if i go into a place if i go
into
a private establishment of some kind
business
home whatever it is and it and i don't
own it
and someone who who does own it or works
there if they tell me
hey we need you to wear the mask i'll
put it on because
it's their place their rules and um
and that's it i'll respect their place
and their rules and also
the random employee at walmart
who's telling you put the mask on it
it's not his rule he didn't make it up
he doesn't want to enforce it he has to
and if he fails to enforce he'll
probably get fired i don't want to get
that that kid fired
so i'll do that like i'm not going to
volunteer to wear the mask
but if someone in a position of
authority
and if you work at it even if you work
at walmart then you you do have a
position of authority at least in case
you work for the employer
um if someone like that
asks me to then i will i'm not going to
volunteer
but if someone who has no authority just
some other person
a fellow customer or someone demands
that i put it on
no sorry because i don't have to listen
to you
you have no authority you have as much
authority here as i do which is none
and then also i i've never quite
understood this why do people care
this this whole time you've had you've
got these complaints about people who
wear the mask wrong or have the mask
pulled below the nose what do you care
if someone has the mask pulled below the
nose
what does it matter to you if you think
it puts them in more danger
that's not your concern do you really
think
if someone has the mask below the nose
which is how i wear mine by the way
uh and not because i don't know how to
wear it i wear it that way because i
want to breathe
that's why i wear it that way so when
you see people at this point
with the mask below the nose no these
aren't morons who don't know how masks
work
they they're wearing it that way on
purpose because it's more comfortable
and it's none of your business what do
you think's gonna happen you think
someone has the mask below the nose they
walk past you in the grocery aisle
do you think just from the air blowing
out of their nostrils as they pass
by you for a second you think that's
going to infect you when you're wearing
a mask
let me tell you something if it does
then if that does happen then the mask
really was useless and so what does it
matter if they're wearing it or not
you know i i love and appreciate all of
our sponsors on this show
um i love and appreciate them deeply and
intimately well maybe not intimately but
i i do i do
appreciate all of them although the more
i love them the better it is and the
easier it is for me to talk about it so
it is really really easy for me to tell
you about constitutioncoach.com and to
uh and to encourage you to take
advantage of this
my friends over at constitutioncoach.com
have a lot of great programs for
equipping citizens to defend liberty by
studying and living out the constitution
i actually just experienced their
constitutional defense course this is
what i was doing over the weekend i
mentioned it yesterday on the show
briefly
uh but i was in nevada at what's called
front sight and i was taking
their training course and i i absolutely
cannot recommend it enough
i was kind of nervous going in i'll
admit but um
uh those nerves quickly were were were
settled and i i
couldn't have been happier to be there
and i'm happy that i went through that
experience you get an amazing
combination of intellectual ammunition
and live classes with rick green
america's constitution coach and then
you also get the physical training at
the premier firearms training facility
in the nation all in the same course
you get to join hundreds of other
patriots from across the nation for a
time of learning training fellowship
with like-minded people whether you have
shotguns your whole life or if you've
never even touched one i'm telling you
these people took me to an entirely
new skill level and they're gonna do the
same for you don't just get a gun learn
how to carry with confidence and get the
training you need
to defend your family it's so important
if you have the gun
you've got to know how to use it that's
what that's what sent me over that's why
i wanted to do this and i'm so happy
that i did you can go to
constitutioncoach.com
and now i am way more confident handling
a firearm than i
ever had been in the past and that's all
thanks to constitutioncoach.com
rick of the constitution coach team have
another class on april 25th but it'll
fill up fast so visit
constitutioncoach.com today
and watch my video there to find out
more about how you can be a part of this
one-of-a-kind training
can't recommend it enough go to
constitutioncoach.com
now if you haven't heard by now um but
honestly if you listen to me as much as
you should
you would have heard by now so you
better have heard that candace owens has
a brand new talk show with us
exclusively at dailywire.com the full
show might be available to daily wire
members only but
candice is also a podcast that you can
listen to on apple spotify or anywhere
else you get your podcast
the candace owens podcast features
several breakout segments from the full
length show including interviews panel
discussions and her advice corner
the podcast is so good in fact that it's
reached number two on the apple podcast
chart just after the first episode so
if you need some candace owens in your
podcast feed look no further head over
to
apple podcast or spotify and subscribe
today be sure to have to leave a five
star review if you like what you hear
now let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
so yesterday the word obesity was
trending on twitter for now from what i
can tell
the reason for this trend was at least
apart the announcement from krispy kreme
that they're going to give you free
donuts well free doughnuts actually
multiple fruit dollars
if you can produce proof that you were
vaccinated for coven
say not just one donut they'll give you
a free donut every day for the rest of
the year
now will anyone actually take them up on
this i mean will anyone bring
their medical paperwork into a krispy
kreme shop every day
for a year to get a free donut well
anyone will anyone get the vaccine just
just for the free donuts i don't know
but if i know anything about americans
the answer is
certainly yes now keep one thing in mind
though
krispy kreme is known for reneging on on
these kinds of promises
there was a time many moons ago when you
could go into a krispy kreme store
any time the hot now light was on and
you could get a free donut
if the sign said hot now and there was a
time many moons ago when
i would often take advantage of that
perk but then and i like to think this
is thanks exclusively to my own
uh gluttonous and greed they stopped
offering the free donuts
at least the krispy kremes around where
i lived that was the case
so now um hot now only means that the
donuts are hot and fresh which of course
means that when the light isn't on
they aren't hot and fresh and that's a
problem because krispy kreme donuts
are exceptional in that they are the
only food item which goes from being
heavenly
as soon as it emerges from the oven to
inedible four minutes later
the donuts are are great when they're
piping hot but downright reprehensible
at room temperature
the second law of thermodynamics has not
been kind to krispy kreme
anyway i seem to have lost the plot
somewhere
uh the the point is that krispy kreme is
trying to help fight covet by giving out
donuts and this is potentially doing
more harm than good
seeing as obesity is one of the major
coveted risk factors
one of the reasons that coveted hit us
so hard is that we have so many obese
people in this country it doesn't seem
like a great idea in light of that fact
to encourage
even more obesity and it is that word
obesity which prompted this tweet from
actress jamila jamil
known for her role in that one show uh
and also that other show
and oh yeah that did you ever see that
thing about the person
doing the thing she's in that too i
think well she whoever she is
she she tweeted this she said quote
obesity trending opens the floodgates to
a tsunami of ignorant and illogical
abuse against the fat community
lacking context nuance and humanity
below is something i want you to
understand
and then there is a picture with even
more text presumably written by her
saying quote obesity is trending on the
subject of obesity and the amount of
people who die allegedly from it
allegedly from it i think it's important
to keep reminding people that a lot of
fat people die or become seriously ill
because their symptoms of serious
illness are ignored by doctors who blame
everything on their weight and therefore
don't investigate their health properly
cancer cysts respiratory brain tumors
life-threatening gynecological issues
etc
often missed by practitioners who are
unable to see past their own fat phobia
so until people who are larger than
average are treated equally by doctors
and not dismissed and dehumanized so
pervasively and frequently
we can't have an informed or fair
conversation about any death rates or
health issues related to obesity
okay now where to start maybe with this
she refers to the number of people who
die allegedly from obesity for the
record as far as that number goes 78
of people hospitalized with covet in the
u.s were overweight or obese
worldwide according to the world health
organization
million people die from obesity related
causes each year
and that's pre-covet those are the
pre-coveted numbers 2.8 million
worldwide it's only gotten worse not
better
jamil mentions that obese people die
from cancer cysts
respiratory issues which are allegedly
missed by the fat phobic doctors well it
turns out that
obesity increases your risk of
developing all of those things
the doctors are not ignoring those
health concerns hazards by telling you
to get your weight under
control they're telling you to get your
weight under control because
of those hazards and countless others
we see here the extent to which the
words like words like equality and
bigotry have lost their coherence
the words quite literally don't mean
anything anymore you may as well not say
them because nobody will know what you
mean when you do
no doctors should not treat obese people
equal to other people
because they're not equal if you're
obese
you are less healthy more at risk more
likely to die
and doctors absolutely ought to be
taking that into account
asking for a doctor to treat fat people
equally is like complaining
when your allergist gives you and gives
you an inhaler
because people without asthma don't need
inhalers so you're being treated
unequally
well you gave me an inhaler what about
him why don't you give him one
well because he doesn't have asthma you
dope
you you are as a person with asthma you
are unequal
to non-asthma people unequal as in not
the same as
you are different you have this risk
factor and they don't
is your doctor being asthma phobic by
giving you that inhaler
i suppose so yeah he is he is rightly
afraid of what asthma might do to you
and so he's trying to treat it in the
same way it is right to be afraid
of what obesity might do to a person fat
phobic
sure i'm fat phobic i announce it
proudly i am fat phobic
i don't want to be fat myself i don't
want my loved ones to be fat
i don't want anyone to be fat i am i am
phobic of that i am phobic of people
being fat
the reason i don't want that for myself
or for anyone else is that i don't want
to die
i don't want anyone else to die being
fat not only can kill you
but it will it will there's a reason why
you rarely see morbidly obese 80 year
olds
the reason is that obesity will shorten
your lifespan you are straining your
body and your internal organs by
carrying around all that extra baggage
eventually your body and your organs
will be taxed to their limits
this is the reality it's not pleasant
but that doesn't make it not real
so for all these extraordinarily obvious
reasons the idea of fat acceptance the
idea that there
you know even is such a thing as the fat
community which we must afford rights
and equality to
let you think about that fat community
it's utter incomplete madness
yet it's predictable madness in a
culture where self-love is not only the
highest love but indeed the only love we
recognize we are encouraged to
focus our sights inward right to value
our emotional well-being above all else
to put
to put ourselves before everything and
everyone to recognize
no moral law but our own whims
we've seen the catastrophic consequences
of living in a civilization that
operates that way
and we've seen in many forms the great
irony
which is that we focus the more we focus
on ourselves the more we demand
acceptance of ourselves and of our vices
the more we love ourselves in this way
the more damage we do to ourselves
we are loving ourselves to death you
might say
even death by krispy kreme and other
assorted
junk foods and for that reason jamila
jamil
whoever she is and all the other
apostles from the church of fat
acceptance
all must be forthwith canceled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day
godspeed
[Music]
the matte wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling our technical
director is austin stevens
production manager pavel vadasky the
show is edited by danny d'amico
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
and makeup is done by nika geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matte wall show is a
daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 21. today on the
ben shapiro show another
mass shooting rocks colorado joe biden
continues to lock kids in cages while
keeping the border open
and democrats aren't done yet they're
calling for an end to the filibuster
that's today on the ben shapiro show
give it a listen